are there people from the government who
watch every one of your appearances
perhaps even watch the appearances of
people like Lou to make sure that you're
not revealing too much and so who are
these people are there multiple
individuals is the department do they
tap your phone I I just got to be
careful what I say I mean I have been
told I should make the assumption that
the things that
I say are being watched not just by us
but by others uh so obviously I I try be
care I try to hold all confidences that
I'm either sworn to or agreed to you
know as best as possible at one level I
can't worry about these people right I
mean I I I've got to just do what it is
that I'm doing uh until somebody tells
me not to do something I'm going to do
it